hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sexy hiking now ignore
the quality of what you see here when I
was playing getting over it he mentioned
this game this game was the inspiration
for getting over it so I wanted to play
and see just how infuriating the
original 2002 game was oh god oh god oh
it's even worse okay alright oh boy
Wow how's it going there friend oh oh I
do not like you okay alright I see
what's going on here
I see exactly where you got inspired to
do this [ __ ] oh boy okay hang on pop
oh boy yup oh no oh well there I go then
there's some Oh what was that
oh boy no god damn it
oh you sack of [ __ ] oh you're gonna be
just as hard as the other one aren't you
how the hell cuz you can't you can't you
can't bring your hammer around fast
enough what I don't know what happened
oh boy so obviously this game is meant
to be frustrating that much is readily
apparent but how frustrating is the
question right yeah cuz I literally
cannot swing my hammer around fast
enough to be able to get where I need to
go so I have to be able to well there's
gotta be a way right
whoa hey goddamnit son of a [ __ ]
aye but at least this one is consistent
like it's [ __ ] obviously but at
least this one's consistent huh anything
like that anything like that
god damn it I'm gonna get mad over this
one he was right you were gonna be
fumbling around the [ __ ] tree in the
opening goddamn segment of the game for
ten hours if you figure out though all
right well as you figure out what the
heck you're supposed to do here that
doesn't make any goddamn sense
I can't it's something like it you can
you can horror voff you can harm for
yourself
okay oh [ __ ] how are you supposed to
hurt and catch is that what you're
supposed to do you're supposed to harm
from catch well why didn't it hurt hey
oh oh I heard sting caught oh god damn
it oh it's only what I like what if I
was just flailing against madness here I
wouldn't be too upset about her you know
is the thing right like if I was just if
I was just sabja if I was just
subjecting myself to impossible [ __ ]
I wouldn't ever I wouldn't care right I
wouldn't care it's because I care that I
uh
[ __ ] it's because I care so much that's
why I I'm an amazing person that's why
that's why I'm conversing okay well you
have to be just off of the edge of it
hit that - hey no no no no what are you
doing what are you doing stop stop ah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa easy up there
Homer Oh easy there easy there easy
derry-o no you know what I ain't gonna
do that well why do I need to do that
when I can do this maneuver alright
alright alright
why alright we're making progress we're
making stupid progress but we're making
progress nonetheless okay ah I was I was
just wondering if it was like an
invisible or a horrible place you know
like since Maddie okay I don't know what
happened there
that was not white why are you humping
so weak just humph it okay there we go
why can't you hump it right here hump it
right here right here this is where you
do huh
no don't hump that just grab that uh Oh
what are you what are you what are you
are you a checkpoint please tell me
you're a checkpoint huh oh god I got the
first level why checkpoints well that
can't be right well that can't be right
at all oh well this looks [ __ ] oh
yeah this looks indeedy-do [ __ ] god
damn it oh this is gonna be a sack of
tits ain't it okay how do you expect how
in the heck okay all right okay
ah no Humphrey no open right now please
plebes no humph no you just clipped
through that like your Sackett it's okay
no hum Fionn no humping god this musics
hype oh come on you sack of [ __ ]
oh just pack up your I don't know what
backup your [ __ ] and that's take it
to the state fear God my insults are
getting worse and worse no no come on
stop doing that at least this one
doesn't have the infuriating loss of
progress [ __ ] but going an inch
might as well be going a mile in this
sack of tits
am i hitting the top of it or something
got a humph away God but if I humph away
I can't get how did I get this the first
try this is always how it goes I get
something on the first goddamn truck
come on what are you doing now now I
don't even know what you're doing okay
can you just why can't you just get fair
now what the hell he's humping at
everything now God why why just why what
is he suddenly humping at everything
why No
how did I get this on the fur how did I
get this on the first try god [ __ ]
damn it why why is that weak why son of
a [ __ ] this isn't even that god this oh
come on just stay on the [ __ ] ledge
oh why I can't even get up fair now why
why why would you be weak there I'm not
doing anything
look hands are off
don't ask me because I don't have a
[ __ ] clue what's going on seriously
how did I get this the first time how I
don't understand oh just barely there
okay let's try this again but less
stupidly huh see I'm not doing that
bounce I am NOT doing that bounce
I'm not about that bounce well why you
clipped through again why does he clip
through I am well outside of your
boundary [ __ ] oh no no no no no come on
it just clips through well that's not
even fair well that's not even fair it's
just a broken game at that point
come on 2002 developer get your head out
of your ass and make this game oh
[ __ ] hell okay okay okay okay okay
yeah baby yeah baby yeah baby yeah baby
yeah baby okay
right this is where things might get a
little dicey cuz there's no way than I'm
gonna be able to move okay I have to
push off and grab the tippy-top of that
maybe I don't maybe I don't maybe I
don't maybe it's maybe this is just a
fool's errand to try to do that but I
don't think
I'm not gonna be able to I've done this
with the other brands that look just
like this yeah that's not gonna work
okay why did I go bouncy like that hi
you bounce you like that whoa okay god
dammit god dammit no wonder this game is
[ __ ] infuriating no wonder everyone
loves it Nora that guy loves it no
honour Bennet Fadi loves this game come
on I'm obviously not humping back if you
could all if you could just stop being a
bag of dicks please oh god I just want
to get to the top of this one the second
level I want to get to the top of the
second level there really so much to ask
okay that was weird
Berlioz is nodding yes yes it is too
much to ask you sack of [ __ ] don't even
know why it's you shaking it's not me
it's you why does he shake it slow it's
like some weird juxtaposition of if you
do it if you hold too long the mouse
gets all kinds of confused why that made
no sense I think it's I think it's you
have to hold the mouse as far away from
like your actual why you are huffing up
a storm good god you shaky bastard why
[Music]
why the hell do you choose to be a
stupid idiot you could be a smart pants
cuz you only are pants you have no body
god oh [ __ ] off with you Jesus Christ oh
my god are you kidding me see this game
it's not as it's not as like painful as
the other one the other one had steaks
like you made progress you did it this
one is just a sack of [ __ ]
like that's the only thing that's oh god
that's the only thing that's bad about
this game is that it's a sack of
inconsistent [ __ ] and it's probably
broken it's probably a hundred percent
broken the reason getting over it is
like emotionally scar oh [ __ ] off the
reason why getting over it is
emotionally scarred why can't I get I am
as gentle as a [ __ ] butterfly right
now the reason why getting over it is so
emotionally traumatizing is because you
do make all this progress why did you
just phase through that why did you do
that and when you make so much progress
and it tortures you because it shows you
what you could have done like oh come on
all right I'm only gonna give us a few
more tries I'm only gonna walk straight
into hell a few more times guys I'm only
gonna put these bees in my eyeball a few
more times and then I'm gonna then I
might even find out yeah I just I just
want to know maybe it won't sting me in
the eye like the third or fourteenth oh
no it stung me again the bees that I put
in my eyes well let me hear let me climb
up this mountain let me let me dip my
balls in lava let me just do that let me
see if that I don't know it her like it
burns him off the first time maybe it
won't happen the 17th time maybe maybe
it won't let me try that Oh God let me
try Oh God hey you know getting over it
scarred me bad enough why don't I play
the original progenitor that's probably
even worse than it oh yeah that's
probably good idea [ __ ] hell Oh oh
god it's getting to me it's getting to
me it's getting to me it is getting to
me it is getting me is getting me it's
got me it's got me in its grasp it's got
me and it's hammer II grasp stop that
whatever whatever that is just don't do
that
all you have to do is not do the shaky I
don't get that see look look look
look I don't know why it's choosing to
be shaky see I'm far away it's not as
shaky get closer shaky
far away no shaky closer shaky no no
come on you shaky piece of [ __ ] it's
like a it's like a random number
generator on how many bones he's gonna
disappear and riparian his body [ __ ]
okay well you know see what I don't get
is sometimes you go big jump sometimes
you you know I don't know I [ __ ] help
guys I don't know I'm gonna stick my
head in the lion's den just a few more
times just a few more times I want to
know how it feels on the thirty second
time the lion rips my face off I just
slide right in there we go
now just slide right in no just slide
back and slide back in and slide back in
slight slide back it it's it's literally
all you I do is slide back in slide in
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm done I don't
need to put myself through this [ __ ]
I don't need to stick my hand in a
gorilla mating patch I don't need to
rock poison ivy on my penis so I'm not
gonna torture myself cuz I don't need to
I don't want to play this game getting
over it made me want to keep playing it
this game no it's just an exercise in
futility because the [ __ ] game is
broken as [ __ ] and done work so if you
want to play sexy hiking it's free I'll
put in the for some reason if for some
reason you want toward yourself I'll put
sexy hiking in the description below so
that you can absolutely ruin your day
just if you want that just go for it you
know what I ain't even gonna question
you I'm trying to phase myself through
this wall here man
wait I think he's I think he's on to
something pickle I can't see him she's
moving fast God it just rejects you it
just rejects you that's all it really is
anyway I'm done so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know
anything down the comments below and as
always
you in the next video
[Music]